我们今天就来深入猜解一下传奇交易员巨人杰
他的投资脑袋到底在想什么
他那套能把生活观察变成真金白银的逻辑
到底是怎么一回事
这整套分析都是根据他在Joman访谈里亲口讲的心法
好我们马上开始
我们就从这句话开始看
哇这句话可以说是颠覆了很多人的想象
对吧
他直接点出巨人节交易哲学的核心
就是说真正的厉害之处
不是你找到什么神秘指标
而是你得先回头看看自己
搞定自己的问题
这也为我们今天的讨论
定下了一个很重要的T调
好那今天我们会聊些什么呢
首先我们会先搞懂
他认为交易的关键到底是什么
然后再来拆解他最重要的两个战术
风暴笔跟试单
还有它是怎么看待赔钱这件事的
最后我们会用一个超精彩的能源产业案例
来看它这些想法在真实世界是怎么运作的
OK那我们就进入第一部分
交易的真正关键
在讲任何买卖技巧之前
你得先记住巨人节深信不语的一点
交易这场游戏有九成打的都是心理战
这就是他的核心信念
他觉得你交易能不能有所突破
关键根本不是去学什么很厉害的图表分析
而是要先解决自己内部的四个大问题
你就要问自己
我的心态稳不稳
我的钱有没有管好
我用的杠杆会不会盖大
还有我到底为什么要买这个部位
他说如果连这些最基本的问题都想不清楚
那你学再多技术分析
其实都是百搭
哇这句话讲的超狠对吧
这就很清楚的表达出他对技术分析的态度
他不是说技术分析完全没用哦
不是这个意思
他的重点是
如果一个人把输赢的全部希望都寄托在这些外部工具上那就表示他忽略了最根本的东西就是我们刚讲的心态跟资金管理对他来说真正的答案在别的地方
好
那既然心态这么重要
具体上到底要怎么做呢
我们就来看
他的第一个实战技巧
怎么轻通风暴笔
而这一切的起点
都来自一个
听起来很简单
但其实潮激强大的概念
叫做试单
这个试单听起来好像很玄
但其实拆开来看
步骤很清楚
第一步
你先用一个小到你根本没感觉的部位开始
比如说就只买一股
你没听错就是一股
第二步
这一步就有点反人性了
你要刻意放大赔钱的痛苦
这点我们等一下会细讲
第三步
只有当你越来越有信心的时候
才慢慢把部位加上去
白话文就是
你的信心有多少
你的单子就下多大
完全成正比
那这样做到底聪明在哪里
关键就在那个不对称的风险
你想想看
当你看对方向的时候
哇
你可能已经加码到一百股了
赚的是一百股的钱
万一看错了呢
拍谢
我赔的只是最一开始那一股的钱
所以他追求的
从来就不是什么很高的胜率
而是要确保赢的时候要赢大的
输的时候要输小的
好接下来这个部分
我觉得是今天最
最繁直觉
但可能也是最精华的地方
我们要来谈谈
巨人节是怎么利用亏损的
你听好哦
是利用亏损
让赔钱这件事变得有它的价值
你看这张图
左边是不是超像我们平常会做的事
哎呀才赔一点点没关系啦
放着总有一天会长回来
但对巨人节来说完全不是这样
任何亏损就算只是赔那一股的钱
对他来说都是一个红色警报
那个警报器就在跟你大叫说
喂你当初买他的理由可能不见了哦
他就是靠这种刻意放大的痛感来训练自己养成钢铁般的停损纪律。这句话真的太经典了,把那种纪律推到极致。
所以你看,它的停损点不是什么跌5%就砍,跌10%就卖,不是这种死板的数字。
它只问自己一个最核心的问题,我当初买进的理由还在吗?
如果答案是不在了,就算才刚买进一秒钟,它也会马上出场。
这个观念超级重要
因为等一下那个能源的例子
完全就是靠这个原则在操作
OK 理论讲了这么多
听起来好像有点抽象
对吧 没关系
我们直接来看一个横跨好几年的实战案例
你就懂了
看他是怎么把前面讲的那些心法战术
全部串在一起
打出一场超级漂亮的仗
好 我们跟着这个时间轴走一次
故事是从2023年开始的
当全世界都还在玩ChatGPT
惊叹AI有多厉害的时候
巨人节已经在想一个更深层的问题了
这东西这么耗电
以后电要从哪里来
刚好那时候郭台铭提到了SMR这个概念
就是小型核电厂
这就点燃了他的好奇心
结果他顺着这条线索一查
不得了发现OpenAI的老板Sam Altman
竟然就是SMR公司OKLO的董事长
这个连结太关键了
于是他就开始布局
但故事还没完
真正的转捩点
是后来他问了自己一个关键问题
这句话就完美解释了
为什么后来OKOL股价大跌
他不但没卖还继续买
这就回到我们刚刚讲的那个重点了
对吧
他的出厂理由是买进的原因消失
他当时就问自己
Sam Altman跑了吗
没有
AI不用电了吗
当然要
SMR没前景了吗
也没有啊
既然买进的理由都还在
那市场现在恐慌下跌
对他来说
这不是危机
这是打折
好 来了
这就是那个价值连宠的问题
他发现SMR是个很棒的未来
没错
但那是2028年以后的事了那中间这几年呢2025年就要用的店怎么办从哪里来这个问题让他原本的投资布局整个升级了
就是这个问题让他找到了下一个目标
bloom energy
你看这张比较图就非常清楚了
OKLO卖的是什么
是一个我答应你未来会有电的承诺书
是远期的支票
那bloom energy呢
他卖的是我现在就有电给你的解决方案
是手上的现金90天就能搞定
一个是画大饼
一个是端牛肉
你懂那个差别吗
没错
所以他这一步棋走得真的很高明
他等于是把手上的未来承诺书
换成了一份现在进行式的合约
他没有否定原来的看法
而是把它变得更完整更扎实
这个逻辑的升级真的太漂亮了
好看完这个超级精彩的案例
我们拉回来想一想
这些东西对我们来说有什么可以学的
要怎么用在我们自己的投资甚至是生活上呢
我们来快速复习一下今天最重要的四个心法
第一心态心态永远摆第一
先管好自己再管市场
第二把每一次赔钱都当成一次很贵的学费
去感受它分析它不要假装没看到
第三用超小的试单去测试你的想法
有信心了再慢慢加码
第四也是我觉得最棒的一点
最好的点子真的就在你身边
所以绕了一大圈
我们又回到一开始那句话了
真实的大机会
真的不用去什么神秘的社团
或是找什么神奇的老师
他往往就藏在你对身边事物的敏锐观察里
你看它就是从一个大家都在用的ChatGPT
看到了整个国家能源的未来
那么最后我也想问问你
在你每天上下班的路上
在你上班的公司里
在你跟朋友吃饭聊天的时候
有没有什么是你看到了
但别人还没发现的机会或线索呢
搞不好下一个像能源这样的大机会
真的就藏在你最熟悉的地方
等着你把它挖出来而有